last week Tucker reported on the biggest
story of the year the biggest story
liberals have run out of racist statues
to take down so they've now moved on to
racist trees in the California desert
the city of Palm Springs wants to chop
down a grove of 60 year-old tamarisk
trees that stands between a golf club
and a black residential neighborhood if
you're thinking hey wait a minute
I'm liberals supposed to be tree huggers
well yes unless you're planting a racist
tree the city believes these trees were
planted with racist intent others say it
was to prevent some chaps sauntering in
his Plus Falls from calling for his
Niblick and chipping that golf ball
straight through your window but that's
always the cover for racism isn't it
people don't go out and say we're doing
this for a racist reason they go out and
say we're going to give you landscaping
in fact we're going to landscape you
right out of existence and oh by the way
these trees are going to protect you
from golf balls so just like mace golf
balls flying through your kitchen window
is a social construct don't worry about
it
the tamarisk is now the robert e lee of
trees it's robert e tree and liberals
suddenly have no more desire to hug that
tree than they do to hug Charlie Rose or
Matt Lauer the tamarisk is not just
racist it's nasty the African America
the black families whose properties are
adjacent to those trees and if you've
done any research on the tree you'll
know that's one of the nastiest trees
around and it's also been declared an
environmental disaster by the federal
government now because that tree is a
foreign tree you're calling it nasty so
to invert barbara walters if this tree
were a celebrity what celebrity would it
be I am a nasty woman the tamarisk is
nasty and foreign but wait a minute as
we just heard in California everything's
foreign an illegal immigrant can get a
driver's license free health care a nun
law
full immigrant can practice law in
California the one thing he can't do is
stand on the edge of a golf course
covered in foliage on that everyone's a
nativist okay so you are you in need of
us now when it comes to vegetation
absolutely eucalyptus trees have become
a real problem with tipping over it's
too early so liberals are in favor of
open borders for people they're not for
trees tamarisks are found all over the
Muslim world but this is one Muslim ban
they're willing to support when you come
to America you can bring your prayer
rooms you're here jabs your mosques your
Sharia law but you let better leave your
tamarisk back in tamarisk is stan not in
my stand says California you can have
your choice of female head cover but not
a tree cover you have to assimilate with
American trees because just like certain
excitable young men of an extremist
persuasion the tamarisk is prone to self
combust
Tammis trees themselves have been
explosive during these fires that have
been happening so not only do we have
the aspect of the traditional the origin
of the planting of these trees being to
separate the black and people of color
community across the street after their
homes were demolished by the way by the
city of Palm Springs under racist
conditions so just like a Klansmen the
tamarisk stands on your lawn and sets
everything alight as the old Christmas
Carol says o tamarisk o tamarisk how
racist are thy branches what can we
replace the tamarisk with a nice stand
of eucalyptus I think your guest last
night mentioned eucalyptus so it's
interesting your guest tonight is saying
no eucalyptus Democrats a decade ago
more trees less Bush Democrats now less
trees more open space to keep an eye on
Harvey Weinstein and Kevin Spacey now
you might think liberals have finally
flown the coop launching this war on
trees they're literally out of their
tree but what if they're right what if
this really is the root cause what if
trees are
here are the three most forested states
in the Union and here are the whitest
states in the Union coincidence